thank you all
for being here
today I know how much this means
for people in Israel who have endured
the worst terrorist attack in
Generations I am proud to be here today
with so many of you our presence here
outside the European Parliament is
significant our gathering held in the
the Simon V lagora is
symbolic our voice is
important and our strong stand against
terrorism is
crucial October 7th is a day that will
go down in global
infamy the world has witnessed Jews
being murdered simply because they were
Jewish again in Israel
we are here with the president of the
European Council the president of the
European commission and all of you as
one to express our solidarity to condemn
the appalling acts of Terror and murder
and to demand the immediate release of
hostages Europe stands ready to help
broker resolutions
but I've said it before and it burs
repeating there is no
justification for
terrorism Hamas is a terrorist
organization they do not represent the
legitimate aspirations of the
Palestinian people they do not offer
solutions they offer
Bloodshed it helps to speak plainly on
October oober 7th Hamas murdered more
than a thousand innocent babies children
women and men and still hold close to
100 more
hostage they opened fire on hundreds of
young people at a music event killing
indiscriminately including EU Nationals
they abducted Young young girls and boys
they took elderly Holocaust Survivors
and dragged them out of their
homes they paraded dead people through
the street like
trophies this is not a time for
whataboutism we have to be clear about
what we are talking about this is Terror
in its worst
form ambassador regev
thank you for being here today this is
Europe and we stand with
you
I would now ask all of you to Mark a
moment of silence to remember the
victims
for
thank
[Music]
you
all
[Music]
the
[Applause]
than
for